[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les footballeurs bordelais maillot
sombre sont venus à Lyon avec
l'intention de continuer sur leur lancer
autrement dit de gagner une fois de plus
comme ils en ont l'habitude sur terrain
adverse sans doute n'aime-t-il pas le
mauvais temps puisque cette fois ils ont
fait un faux pas devant les Lyonnais les
Lyonnais qui au bout d'un quart d'heure
de jeu sur un centre de l'évier gauche
Rambert repris par dynalo ont marqué le
seul et unique but de la partie
malgré une série de contre-attaques très
incisives au cours de la deuxième
mi-temps les joueurs bordelais n'ont pas
pu refaire le handicap résultat il
perdent du terrain au classement du
championnat de France mais ils n'ont pas
perdu tout espoir de remporter le titre
Les Lyonnais d'ailleurs ont les mêmes
ambitions que
le système solaire est organisé et
chaque planète a un rôle à jouer autour
du Soleil la matière est organisée
chaque atome a un rôle bien déterminé à
jouer à l'intérieur de la molécule la
France doit être organisée car tout ne
doit pas dépendre de Paris la structure
urbaine de la France doit être revue car
à l'heure actuelle seuls quatre villes
dépassent 500 000 habitants
[Musique]
pour des raisons bien souvent
historiques on en trouve 6 en Italie
et 11 en Allemagne fédérale
le problème de l'aménagement du
territoire est un problème
d'organisation chaque ville doit avoir
un rôle défini à son échelle à côté de
Paris capitale à l'échelle mondiale il
faut créer deux villes d'importance
européenne
[Musique]
si métropole inter régional
vocation régionale plus une trentaine de
centres urbains
ces villes doivent attirer et garder les
étudiants et les élèves des grandes
écoles
les sièges sociaux des grandes
entreprises
ceux qui veulent se distraire en mettant
à leur disposition les installations
culturelles et sportives indispensables
et surtout ceux qui veulent trouver un
emploi
mais il ne suffit pas de revoir la
structure urbaine de la France si l'on
ignore le problème des grands réseaux de
communication centrée autour de la
capitale un habitant d'Angers se rend à
Dijon s'il veut avoir son rendez-vous
dans l'après-midi il devra faire 100 km
de plus et passer par Paris dont il ne
connaîtra que la navette interga
cette étoile devant Notre-Dame de Paris
et le point de départ des 14 national
les plus importants il faudra donc
moderniser les communications routières
comme à Tancarville créé de grands axes
transversaux aménager les voies
navigables comme le Grand Canal d'Alsace
[Musique]
pour suivre l'électrification des voies
ferrées
[Musique]
dans les grandes villes de province des
aérodromes pour assurer des relations
rapides
améliorer les liaisons internationales
comme il a été fait au Mont Blanc alors
pour eux dans 20 ans la France aura un
tout autre visage
[Musique]
Francis poulain qui est mort avec lui
disparaît un des plus grands musiciens
français de notre époque
le voici juste après la guerre au moment
où il composait la musique de figures
humaines sur un livret de Cocteau les
animaux modèles les mamelles de Tirésias
Stabat Mater autant d'oeuvre qui
témoignent de son talent et de sa
sensibilité
[Musique]
la vague de froid qui sévit sur l'Europe
n'a pas épargné la Hollande et le pays
des moulins et des tulipes a pris des
allures de Labrador du époque pour les
transporteurs auxquels le verglas a
rappelé parfois brutalement les lois
fondamentales de l'équilibre
[Musique]
à part les patineurs les seuls qui
bénéficient des rigueurs de l'hiver sont
les maraîchers en serre qui continuent
de faire pousser la laitue comme un
juillet une salade or mercuriale pour la
table de quelques privilégiés
au Japon l'hiver pose également des
problèmes à ceux qui doivent se déplacer
[Musique]
partir est une affaire de patience et
les trains aux horaires incertains
jouent bien malgré eux ou transsibériens
[Applaudissements]
nation industrielle avant tout le Japon
s'intéresse aux questions de rendement
[Musique]
quant à la fin des neiges par projection
d'eau chaude le remède s'est avéré pire
que le mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsqu'on février 62 France terminait
son premier voyage peu de gens se
doutaient que ce géant des mers n'avait
été au début que cette petite maquette
dont les formes avaient été étudiées et
modifiées plus de 30 fois au bassin des
carènes de Paris
dans son laboratoire qui se situe sur le
plan mondial parmi les plus grands les
essais sont effectués sur des modèles
réduits
dans un bassin long de 155 mètres la
maquette qui va être dirigée par
téléguidage et soumise à une houle qui
compte tenu des dimensions du modèle
réduit correspondrait dans la réalité à
un creux de 8 mai
[Musique]
toutes les réactions du bateau face au
tangage sont enregistrés sur les
appareils installés à bord
[Musique]
la maquette va maintenant subir ses
essais de roulis supportante en valeur
relative des vagues d'un creux de 6
mètres on peut juger de son comportement
par ce qui serait une forte houle
[Musique]
à la suite de ses premiers essais les
modifications nécessaires peuvent être
facilement faites sur les coques de ces
modèles qui sont constitués par un
moulage de cire et de paraffine les
dispositifs anti-roulis sont modifiés et
les rectifications de profil nécessité
par les interactions entre les hélices
et la carène sont effectués
[Musique]
les ateliers peuvent alors calculer
dessiner et fabriqués avec une précision
absolue les formes idéales de l'hélice
du futur navire sur des modèles d'un
diamètre de 20 à 30 cm
[Musique]
enfin les listes définitives et le
gouvernail sont mis en place
[Musique]
c'est dans ce bassin circulaire de 65
mètres de diamètre qui est la plus
grande des installations similaires
existantes dans le monde que se font les
essais de giration c'est ici qu'on
effectué leur dernier essai en modèle
réduit non seulement les bateaux
construits en France mais aussi se
construit dans de nombreux autres pays
grâce à ces modèles qui semblent naître
que des jouets les projets peuvent être
améliorés et les chantiers efficacement
conseillés
ainsi paquebot cargo pétrolier pourront
sillonner les mers aussi sûrement que ce
porte-avion qui lui aussi n'a été au
bassin des carêmes de Paris qu'une toute
petite maquette de scie
[Musique]
il y a l'art il y a la manière celle de
Claude viseuse sculpteur informel
l'amène à se rendre périodiquement dans
une fonderie de Saint-Ouen pour y jouer
avec du métal à 1200 degrés c'est ainsi
que s'épanouit l'inspiration créatrice
autrement dit que le sculpteur libéré
des contraintes du moulage entame
directement son dialogue poétique avec
le métal en fusion ainsi naissent des
formes des images silhouette
indéfinissable et pétrifiée que le
sculpteur a inventé dans l'instant il
les nomme concrètes
[Musique]
Eric Munster lui qui se veut peintre a
une manière disons expéditive de
concevoir l'élaboration de son œuvre ces
instruments des sacs en plastique
remplis de peinture et d'un mélange des
tanins
une allumette
et
tout ceci n'est évidemment pas sans
risque c'est pourquoi Munster au père de
préférence sur les quais de la Seine
[Musique]
voilà il affirme ainsi vouloir faire de
l'art mais on ne peut s'empêcher de le
soupçonner de vouloir d'abord faire du
bruit
cela fait aussi des trous mais comme le
dit l'artiste les trous aussi ça se vend
[Musique]
pensez Alain calma à séduit tous les
spectateurs au cours des championnats
d'Europe de patinage artistiques qui se
sont déroulés cette année à Budapest en
l'absence du tchécoslovaque divine
Kalman avait aucun concurrent à sa
mesure
et au cours de son exhibition tentant
figure livre qu'en figure imposées
jamais personne n'a douté de son succès
final
le couple allemand Marica killus Hans
borner n'a pas eu plus de difficultés
que le Français Alain calma pour
remporter cette année encore le titre de
champion d'Europe
[Musique]
Marika et Hans ont 41 ans AE2 ils ont
tout l'avenir devant eux et la
perspective de faire fortune dans les
rangs professionnels on leur a fait un
pont d'or mais pour le moment il refuse
[Musique]
ils veulent être champion olympique
après cela on verra
[Musique]
s'il continue de patiner avec cet
aisance nul doute qu'il réussiront dans
leurs entreprises en attendant ils ne
sont pas loin de la perfection
[Musique]
une perfection qui leur vaut une
médaille d'or
Alain calma lui aussi ajoute une
médaille à sa collection et ça ne fait
que commencer
[Musique]
le catch qui est en quelque sorte un
cocktail de lutte et de comédie tout à
la fois continue de faire les bonsoirs
des spectateurs parisiens ceux en tout
cas qui aiment les émotions fortes de la
synthèse et renter sur ce point de les
ont pas déçu
Zavatta est venu là pour chercher des
idées entre clown n'est-ce pas
ne nous appelons pas
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
c'est comme cela que l'on fait le pied
sur un RIB
action Hunter martyrise son adversaire
on sent pour l'air même dans la salle
laseresse se prend pour Tarzan ma parole
il est vrai qu'il faut tous les talents
pour faire du catch
et finalement comme il faut bien que
tout cela finisse la sarthèse gagne ce
combat ce sera pour Hunter la prochaine
fois
[Applaudissements]
il est encore rare de trouver des usines
implantées en pleine nature pourtant ce
spectacle existe maintenant pourquoi
parce que des villes de province ont su
les accueillir Pau est un exemple
caractéristique d'une cité en expansion
les facteurs de son développement l'AC
évidemment car cette richesse naturelle
a permis la naissance d'un complexe
industriel unique en France ce sont des
milliers d'emplois qui furent créés dans
cette zone quelque peu déshérités
[Musique]
mais lac n'explique pas l'évolution
démographique de Pau jusqu'à Mourenx une
ville a été créée pour accueillir les
employés du complexe alors quels sont
les motifs qui ont permis à peau de
passer en moins de 10 ans de 40 à 60000
habitants cette ville a joué
essentiellement sur deux tableaux et là
immédiatement installé un institut de
droit des collèges de lettres et de
sciences d'un des locaux provisoires
mais un vaste ensemble universitaire se
prépare
[Musique]
l'enseignement secondaire possède des
locaux pour près de 5000 lycéens
l'enseignement primaire pour plus de
8000 écoliers et un effort tout
particulier a été réalisé en faveur du
technique un lycée prépare les
techniciens et les ouvriers spécialisés
que les industriels recherchent
enfin un centre d'apprentissage féminin
complète l'équipement scolaire
la ville peut également offrir de
nombreux loisirs indispensables élément
pour fixer les cadres éloignés de la
capitale
[Musique]
et sur la construction et l'urbanisme la
ville qui avait la forme d'un V dont le
centre était vide a établi un plan
d'urbanisme dans lequel s'intègre la
construction des facultés et celle des
logements
[Musique]
la possibilité de trouver un logement
est un des facteurs essentiels qui
déterminent le choix d'une localisation
industrielle ce ne sont pas des
industries lourdes comme celles de lac
que la ville veut attirer mais des
industries complémentaires petites
unités d'une centaine d'emplois chacune
déjà plusieurs industriels se sont
établies dans la ville une fabrique de
chaussures une
usine de matériel magnétique d'autres
encore pour orienter cette expansion une
zone industrielle est en voie de
création sur le territoire d'une commune
voisine d'ores et déjà l'activité
commerciale et la preuve que peau a
gagné son pari l'expansion rapide de
peau et le résultat des efforts et des
initiatives d'une ville qui avec raison
sur l'avenir
la reine Elizabeth est le duc
d'Édimbourg ont reçu les cadeaux qui ont
peu de chance de les suivre à Buckingham
Palace
mais la souveraine n'était pas au bout
de ses surprises à l'heure du thé elle
s'est vu offrir comme un tout visiteur
de qualité le traditionnel yagona à base
de plantes et de racines d'arbres
qu'elle a reçu et bu avec une
impassibilité aussi protocolaire que
britannique
c'est la première fois qu'un souverain
britannique visite les Fidji dont
l'accueil aura été particulièrement
chaleureux
[Applaudissements]
dans les steppes de l'Île-de-France on
les a vu rodés à la tombée du jour
la prudence la plus élémentaire impose
de sortir en groupe et en arbre
[Musique]
dans l'épaisseur des fourrés on laissait
à l'affût dès que vient la nuit les
demeures isolées se transforment en
autant de force à brol dont les
occupants sont décidés à lutter jusqu'à
la dernière chevrotine
[Musique]
soucieux de vérifier le bien fondé de
certaines affirmations éminemment
troublantes nos reporters à leur tour se
sont mis en chasse
darder de téléobjectifs on peut être
courageux sans être téméraire ils se
sont lancés sur la trace des animaux
fabuleux l'émotion les guettaient au
détour d'un sentier là la bête
malheureusement elle n'avait pas l'air
tellement sous-alimenté
pendant un bref instant ils ont cru
toucher au but
c'est pour la chasse aux loups
vraiment l'homme est plus encore la
femme est un loup pour l'homme
mais le premier souci d'un reporter est
de rentrer à tout prix avec une histoire
mais c'était une vieille une trêve
vieille histoire d'ailleurs déjà édité à
laquelle personne ne croit plus depuis
longtemps
nos reporters qui tenait à garder leur
place ont finalement trouvé un loup et
d'ailleurs ils ne furent pas les seuls
un vrai loup il est en résidence forcée
en plein Paris au Jardin des Plantes
l'hiver ne désarme pas et la ville de
nagoyaka dans le nord du pays pourrait
en d'autres circonstances sans
orgueillir d'un bulletin d'enneigement
que lui envierait bien des stations de
sports d'hiver
[Musique]
la population de la ville c'est
courageusement attaquer au déblème
entreprise dérisoires car sur des
dizaines de kilomètres la nature est un
fruit sous 4 mètres de neige
la circulation des trains a été
totalement interrompue
des milliers de voyageurs dont beaucoup
furent bloqués pendant des jours dans
leurs wagons chercher un réconfort dans
la prière
des parachutages de vivre ont été
effectués pour parer aux besoins les
plus urgents le premier bilan est lourd
un millier de maisons détruites
[Musique]
plus de 10000 travailleurs ont été
mobilisés pour rétablir les liaisons
indispensables mais que faire de toute
cette neige par train entier elle a dû
être transportée vers les cieux plus
clément du Sud
[Musique]
première étape de leur séjour en
Nouvelle-Zélande la reine Elizabeth et
le duc d'Édimbourg se sont fait
présenter la haute société locale avant
d'entendre 10000 maori en costume
traditionnel exprimé bruyamment leur
allégresse
la Nouvelle-Zélande célébrait ce jour-là
c'est 123 ans de fidélité la souveraine
le 11e anniversaire de son vrai
[Musique]
que l'Amérique lui refuse l'Angleterre
s'équipe en missiles opérationnel Blue
Steel 24 d'entre eux ont été présentés à
la base de scamton de construction
entièrement britannique les Blues Style
utilisent du carburant liquide
[Musique]
le Scadron 6 17 celui des forceurs de
barrage de la dernière guerre sera le
premier équipé de blues style à Eugies
nucléaire Jacques missile possède une
puissance de destruction 50 fois
supérieure à celle de la bombe atomique
d'Hiroshima les 24 blues styles
disponibles représentent la force de
frappe de trois sous-marins pourvu de
fusées Polaris les bombardiers Vulcains
peuvent lâcher leur missiles à 300 km de
l'objectif
ils sont près de 2 millions vivants dans
les montagnes arides du nord de l'Irak
[Musique]
les rutes de leur village disent assez
la pauvreté de ces hommes rudes que sont
les Kurdes cette minorité cependant est
assez jalouse de ces particularistes
pour avoir pris le parti de les défendre
les armes à la main
et le spectacle les quotidiens d'un
partisan apprenante aux enfants d'un
village le maniement d'un fusil
[Musique]
un an et demi les Kurdes étaient entrés
en révolte contre Kacem une révolte qui
ne disposait que de faibles moyens mais
qu'animait des hommes à la détermination
farouche
leur chef nous la Mustapha Barzani avait
précisé son but à un reporter européen
l'autonomie au sein de l'État irakien
certes mais d'abord la chute de celui
qu'il désignait comme un tyran le
général Kacem
du reste n'avait pas chez les Kurdes que
des ennemis réductibles une minorité lui
restait apparemment fidèle mais il est
beau annonçaient plusieurs fois
l'écrasement définitif de la rébellion
cette brigades de l'armée irakiennement
d'entamer la résistance kurde qui aura
finalement contribué indirectement à la
chute du Zaïre
tatat et faisant des prisonniers parmi
les soldats réguliers coupant les ponts
pour se retrancher dans la montagne
cette armée fantôme ne pue jamais être
réduites
[Musique]
elle le fut d'autant moins qu'il arrive
à même d'un tel localité ou d'un tel
autre que la combativité des deux camps
se Moussa au point qu'une tacite
coopération s'établit entre les forces
du gouvernement et les partisans Kurdes
ce n'était pas l'aspect le moins curieux
de cette guerre devenu semble-t-il un
règlement de compte personnel entre les
Kurdes et le général Kacem
[Musique]
ce dernier multipliant les oppositions
avec fini par être pratiquement isolé à
Bagdad après l'avoir chassé du ministère
de la défense où il s'était réfugié les
officiers conjurés l'ont abattu
[Musique]
au lendemain du coup d'État l'épuration
sévissait à Bagdad les chars achetés aux
Russes par Kacem donnait la chasse aux
communistes les soldats posaient pour
les photographes
[Musique]
prêt Cassel
élimine les problèmes sont-ils résolus
pour autant la révolte kurde ayant aussi
pour objet d'obtenir l'autonomie les
montagnards ne sont pas disposées pour
l'instant à déposer purement et
simplement les arbres
les Kurdes ont vu durant un an et demi
brûler leur village et ils n'ont pas
cédé puissantes minorité de l'Irak il
continue de représenter le problème
numéro 1 pour les nouveaux maîtres de
Bagdad
[Musique]
l'étude des volcans ne requiert pas que
des qualités d'hommes de science c'est
ce que prouve le film qui a rapporté
harunta Dieppe de sa dernière expédition
hivernale sur le plus grand volcan
d'Europe l'Etna les membres de la
mission du Centre national de
vulcanologie avec leurs deux chevaux
Sahara ont dû utiliser des bandes de
treillis métalliques pour vaincre au
milieu d'une tourmente polaire la neige
molle entassée dans les creux si bien
que c'est un véritable exploit qu'on
réalisait à la fois le véhicule et les
hommes à l'occasion d'une simple mission
de routine une de ses missions
régulières qui ont pour but en quelque
sorte la surveillance du turbulent
volcan sicilien
depuis 1960 des spécialistes belges
français et italiens se donnent ainsi
périodiquement rendez-vous à 3325 mètres
au bord de ce cratère dont les colères
ont un de foi éprouvé les hommes là il
se livre à une auscultation un règle les
enregistrements sismologiques leur
permettent de prendre si l'on peut dire
le poux du volcan qui depuis 12 ans n'a
pratiquement passé c'est d'accuser une
certaine fière
Haroun tajv et ses compagnons complètent
leurs observations par des prélèvements
de lave et de gaz au point précis où le
rock en fusion apparaît à l'air libre
[Musique]
part de telles visites les éruptions
catastrophiques du célèbre volcan
sicilien peuvent être sinon prévenu du
moins prévu par ces modernes médecins du
globe
[Musique]
au nombre des milliers de spectateurs
parisiens du Palais des Sports
inconnaisseur Georges Carpentier un
connaisseur qui tout comme le public n'a
pas beaucoup apprécié le combat entre
l'Américain purkin et le Cuba Garcia
Perkins cheveux presque rap porte une
culotte à bande plus foncée que celle de
son adversaire
on attendait 11 et merveilles du duel de
ces deux grands boxeurs candidats au
titre de champion du monde des Walter
junior on attendait à combattre sévère
on a vu qu'une exhibition sans grand
intérêt un combat de gentleman dans un
salon l'arbitre a même dû intervenir
pour demander aux deux boxeurs de ne pas
se moquer du public
de fait au cours des 10 rounds et Garcia
ont échangé que des pichenettes
et où sont donc les grands boxeurs
[Applaudissements]
qui te double pour les Français maillots
et culottes blanches à twekenham devant
l'équipe d'Angleterre autrement dit
c'était le match à ne pas perdre pour
avoir une chance de remporter une fois
encore le tournoi des saint nations
cette chance les Français ont l'air de
vouloir la prendre à pleine main 10ème
minute de jeu attaque classique ponctué
cependant par un essai assez heureux il
faut bien en convenir
et c'est transformé de surcroît par Al
balader
mais ce n'est là que fait pas il
l'équipe de France n'est plus qu'elle
était les années précédentes l'équipe
anglaise non plus résultats un match
intense par l'activité des joueurs mais
sans grand intérêt quant à la qualité
les anglais sont incapables d'attaquer
avec efficacité
[Musique]
premier 3 points c'est sur un coup franc
de Will Cox qui le marque on s'attend en
définitive à une victoire étriquée des
français ce qui ne serait peut-être pas
tout à fait injuste mais car il y a un
mais le sort va en décider autrement sur
cette mêlée justement hors jeu de Fabre
couvrant trois points de plus pour
l'Angleterre la France a perdu cette
année le tournoi des Saint-Vincent
la France continue de grelotter et
Barrie à son tour s'est réveillé sous un
manteau de neige et de glace
dans les rues transformées en patinoire
se déplacer est devenu une aventure et
les transports en commun n'ont jamais
autant mérité leur nom
[Musique]
de ses doigts
ce peintre a fixer un aspect insolite de
la butte promis par d'autres au rang de
station de ski
le long du circulaire pardon du
remonte-pente les skieurs confirmés et
les glisseurs du dimanche ont dévalé la
piste de super-manmartre se donnant pour
un instant l'illusion des transports
d'hiver
ions seulement vite dissipé par
l'apparition du képi reprobateur
[Musique]
15 glacée ne paraît pas avoir affecté
outre mesure le moral des pensionnaires
plus ou moins exotiques du jardin
zolologique tous semblent prendre la
chose avec philosophie il est vrai que
leur situation matérielle est des plus
privilégiée car en pleine nature
beaucoup d'animaux et d'oiseaux ne
survivront pas assez longues semaines de
froid et de faim
les conséquences de cet hiver rigoureux
sont tragique pour les cultivateurs
bretons le marché au cadran de
saint-paul-de-léon évite de marchandises
et d'acheteurs 60% des choux-fleurs et
artichauts consommaient en France ont
été littéralement dévastés par le gel
ceux qui ont pu échapper au massacre
n'ont plus atteindre leur pleine
maturité une perte qui se chiffre à 100
millions de francs 6000 exploitations
agricoles sont en difficulté
[Musique]
mais le Sénégal avec sa production de
légumes en constante augmentation a
pensé à ses amis français l'initiative
personnelle a donné soudain aux envois
de vivre frais et de poissons une
extension exceptionnelle et c'est à
raison d'une tonne par jour que l'angust
haricots verts salade et tomates sont
acheminées par Air France en 5 heures de
vol
l'expansion industrielle en permettant
la création d'emplois est souvent le
seul moyen de sortir des villages ou des
villes de leur léthargie ici c'est un
simple atelier d'une cinquantaine de
personnes qui s'installent dans un vieux
moulin et évite ainsi à quelques
dizaines de familles une pénible
migration
un Château du Loir bourgade de 5000
habitants ancien relais de bagnard la
fermeture d'un dépôt de la SNCF occupant
plusieurs centaines de personnes amena
une dégradation de l'activité économique
pour la redresser des usines furent
construites et mises en location-vente
formule originale qui a réussi et qui a
donné une réelle expansion à cette ville
où 800 emplois ont été créés mais à
l'heure de l'automation le problème de
la main d'oeuvre reste le problème clé
des yeux et des mains deux qualités
qu'une machine usuelles ne peut pas
remplacer des yeux et des mains de
qualité que peuvent offrir des
travailleurs sans formation
professionnelle
[Musique]
industrielle à grande échelle que nous
trouvons installez dans le voisinage
immédiat des nouveaux immeubles où là où
j'ai une grande partie de la main
d'oeuvre disponible l'usine amena la
création d'un centre intellectuel en
liaison avec la Faculté des Sciences
centre qui forment les ingénieurs de
l'industrie électronique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désirant limiter à 2000 le personnel de
l'usine de Dijon cette industrie
installa des annexes dans 5
agglomérations voisines comment choisir
une commune dans chaque mairie ceux qui
désiraient travailler dans l'industrie
se faisait inscrire un deuxième élément
intervenait on cherchait de la main
d'oeuvre masculine seul bonne avec ses
12000 habitants pouvaient permettre de
la trouver
[Musique]
on désirait de la main d'oeuvre féminine
Genlis pouvait l'offrir ayant déjà réglé
par ailleurs le problème de l'emploi des
hommes
[Musique]
l'usine se rapproche donc de la main
mieux dans un rayon de quelques
kilomètres un quart va chercher les
ouvriers à proximité de leur domicile
cette expérience va donner un nouvel
essor à la vieille capitale
bourguignonne et à toute sa région
[Musique]
au bureau comme à la chasse le style
c'est l'homme dieu merci nous n'en
sommes plus au temps où l'homme
abandonnait sa voiture à des
improvisations incertaines l'homme 63
accusera donc un certain allongement
ainsi en ont décidé de les mettre
ailleurs
[Musique]
il aimera le par dessus pied de coque
pour le voyage il aimera les bas de
pantalon dissymétriques beaucoup plus
long derrière que devant de l'audace
encore de l'audace il portera des
chapeaux personnalisés et le soir avec
le smoking il endossera le gilet de la
mer argentée
[Musique]
aux accessoires c'est sur la Tour Eiffel
qu'ils ont eu la vedette on y a vu
fleurir des parapluies aux mains de
Michel JAZY de Marcel Cerdan junior de
judoka et d'autres athlètes une manière
comme une autre de célébrer tout à la
fois la saint Pépin et l'adoption par
les sportifs du parapluie réputé jadis
symbole de limbourgeoisement bien à tort
si l'on en juge par l'usage qu'on peut
faire à l'occasion un Gilles de la mare
et quelques autres
voici donc l'homme parait pour la grande
offensive de printemps et dans cette
offensive générale déclenchée par la
haute couture parisienne voyons comment
Mark born a traité dans sa collection
les rapports de la mode et de la couleur
[Musique]
beaucoup de couleurs puisque ce sont
celles du Printemps des vers en
particulier tous les Verts grinçants
acidulés mouillés avec cela une ligne
effilée quels sont les règles d'or que
Dior a suivi cette année
les grands cercles qui tiennent lieu de
chapeau sont là pour accentuer encore
cette silhouette longue et mince des
prochains cocktails
[Musique]
apparition légère aérienne pourrait-on
dire Ascott robe d'organisent
comme le manteau
absente robe et veste de crêpes vertes
citronnade tailleur de chantung jaune
citron bien sûr avec une blouse brave et
blanc
porte-bonheur en organdi blanc trois
ensemble court pour le soir et pour le
charme
pour le grand soir et pour le grand
charme des robes longues de crêpes
vertes
ou de gaz rose également brodé chez Dior
le printemps est déjà là
[Musique]